obviously
as you can probably see from my face
um
i have uh
this syndrome called uh
um ramsey hunt syndrome
justin bieber gives a help update after
revealing he has a rare facial paralysis
syndrome the pop star says he's leaning
on his faith through it all i think it's
just my job to be a light
and share what i've been
what i went through as far as
my spiritual my spiritual journey justin
hopped on instagram tuesday to update
his fans writing a lengthy post sharing
insight on his road to recovery quote
each day has gotten better and through
all the discomfort i have found comfort
in the one who designed me and knows me
so for those who are frustrated by my
cancellations of the next shows um
i'm just physically obviously not
capable of doing them
uh this is pretty serious as you can see
and um
i hope you guys understand
and uh
i'll be using this time to just rest and
relax and
get back to 100
so that i can um
do what uh
i was born to do you give me purpose
[Music]
when he first revealed his diagnosis the
biebs announced he had to postpone all
concert dates indefinitely for his
justice world tour
such an honor to be back here
in his update justin gets deep about his
faith specifically how god knows the
darkest parts of me yet constantly
welcomes me in his loving arms adding
this perspective has given me peace
during this horrific storm that i'm
facing i know this storm will pass but
in the meantime jesus is with me i have
hope and um i trust god and um i trust
that this is all gonna
it's all for a reason and um
i'm not sure what that is right now but
in the meantime
i'm gonna rest and
i
i love you guys
[Music]
you